foreign
Lexington Kentucky what's up Daniel how
we doing
pretty good how are you doing Dr deloney
good man good good good good so what's
up
I guess my main question I have for you
is how do I deal with the disgust I have
toward my dad
oh man right when you said how do I I
started to sing that song but this is
actually a serious question man how do
we live so um like uh
why do you disgusted with your dad
well first of all I gotta say the story
is like an onion there is just layer
upon layer upon layer so I'll I'll try
to tell pretty much everything in under
a couple minutes or so cool
um so I'm 29 I'm a husband father of
three my dad is a sex addiction
therapist uh two years ago he cheated on
my mom with one of his clients in his
office
at the time he was 63 years old she was
29.
so
as a result my mom divorced my dad they
were married for 43 years
and there's some important details about
his mistress so after this all happened
I learned that she served an eight-year
prison sentence for sexual enticement of
a minor and after her she served her
prison time she was ordered by a judge
to receive Psychotherapy which is why
she was seeing my dad so the story
behind why she went to prison in the
first place is that at one point she was
working as a prostitute and exposed
herself to two 12 year old boys
so it gets worse
so uh when she was young she was in a
car accident and it left her with some
residual brain damage so I met her in
person and she still struggles with some
executive brain function I'm not a
psychologist but
um I would say she has the cognitive
function of a 13 year old person
probably which just adds to how you know
unethical this was okay
so shockingly my dad uh decided to marry
this woman
um and even to this day he doesn't
really believe that he's done anything
unethical he justifies it by saying that
it was consensual
so
um I will say that there he's been
reported to the Licensing Division and
um there's an investigation going on
right now so here's what I really need
help with
um so I obviously I feel a lot of
disgust towards my dad and really the
entire situation I feel a lot of
resentment and I feel abandoned and
betrayed but if I'm really honest with
myself I also miss him deeply from my
life and my kids lives as well so I
haven't spoken to him in about five
months and I'm just wondering where do I
go from here
huh
I'm sorry man
on 50 different counts I'm sorry
um
this is a messy situation that is
much simpler than it feels and much
um heavier than you probably think it's
going to be over the long term okay
um the chance that this was the first
time this happened is virtually zero
oh I I know it's not the first time it's
happened okay all right so
um it's very rare that a somebody who
deals in the intimacy of other people's
lives who is a person of this kind of
character wouldn't have done this
multiple times and
that you will you you you get four or
five drinks and your mom she might tell
you all about some stories that have
happened along the years right
um yeah here's the deal that's not gonna
change where you find yourself you find
yourself disgusted with a guy let me
tell you where a lot of us don't realize
how deep this disgust goes
because as much as we don't want to
think about it or believe it or we don't
even consider it
we all know deep down that half of us as
Mom and half of us as Dad
and if he is capable of this what am I
capable of because I'm part of him and
he's part of me
right yeah it's unnerving it makes it
particularly close and then you throw it
on top the confusion of I actually like
the guy and I miss him being around but
he's also disgusting like and then you
just find yourself in this Vortex right
yeah so here's the heartbreaking thing
he has opted out of your life not the
other way around
yeah I think that's true he opted out of
your mom's life he opted out of your
life
um and he's throwing away his entire
career he's going to be found guilty
right we know that uh he'll be found
guilty because they're going to take his
text messages they're going to take his
uh emails they're going to take all of
his clinical records and probably dig up
the times this has happened in the past
so it's the the it will be a hurricane
Cha-Cha storm diarrhea storm coming down
the road
um and he
walked into it all right
and I I have a very little sympathy for
somebody in his case because people come
to him and they're most vulnerable and
they come to him with a particularly
vulnerable thing which is I'm addicted
to relationship right and he abused that
and so I I don't got a lot I'm disgusted
by him too let me say that
um yeah and I mean that's that's why I
view her as a victim really in this
situation I mean I feel absolutely on
some level absolutely absolutely yeah
she went to a professional for help and
took advantage of that help so
the the thing you can do is walk away
and after you walk away
um
any choice you make to go back and be
redisgusted and rediscussed it as a
choice you're making to be more
miserable in the present I wouldn't do
that
yeah you know what I mean there's no
sense in poisoning yourself
you do have to reckon with
um
that guy's part of me and what am I
doing in my life that could ever even
have a a the faintest trail into the
woods that would lead me down a path
like this
mm-hmm sure is there anything in
yourself that makes you uncomfortable or
is this just your dad off the rails
um
sad you know okay um it I it often when
our parents do things there's Echoes
inside of us
yeah I think the the what makes it
particularly difficult is
growing up I I I always thought of them
as for the most part a really good while
they're teaching you know good values
and so after this has happened it's sort
of it's sort of like well was all that
fake was all that an act you know like
that's that those are the thoughts that
are going through my mind like were
those things that I was even taught was
it even real because the person who
taught it to me
just totally went the opposite direction
you know and you're 29 right now
yeah that's right you'd be having these
thoughts anyway
like 20 27 28 to 33 35 that's when you
start pulling the thread on is this real
and you because you start moving up the
professional ladder and you look behind
the curtain and you realize oh my boss
doesn't know what he's doing at all and
you your doctor has a different
conversation they're like I don't know
man I gotta go check with a colleague
and you think I thought y'all know
everything right so this is the season
when everything like your friend gets
fired or your wife gets fired or
something like that so this is the
season when everything starts unwinding
a little bit and then the the thing you
were anchored into the man that you
anchored into
turns out he wasn't conquered he's just
a Mist right
and the Temptation is to throw
everything out
don't do that if he gave you good wisdom
and good values even though he wasn't
using them
um
honor those things right
yeah but yeah you're married
yeah okay you ever cheat on your spot on
your on your wife
no uh-uh
don't okay
okay yeah I won't I know but don't
yeah we learn our behaviors right
right and cheating starts with Cuban
secrets
and cheating starts with flirting here
in the office and cheating starts right
see what I'm saying so I want you to
Sure hold the thread on those you're
you're you're suddenly going uh uh
these are when our parents screw up it
echoes through us okay
not to say that you're some a sex
criminal which is what I think your dad
is
but uh you do
um
you do have these Echoes In your own
soul okay
and man you got to walk away he left you
and now you're just standing there you
got to go be about your life and I know
that's so hard man here's the way like
tactically here's how we do this number
one you're gonna write him a letter okay
and I it might be one that you consider
mailing to him
okay okay normally we write these
letters and it's not one of rage and
anger and uh like some out of some some
superiority
it's out but feel free to let him know
like you broke my heart man
because you didn't tell the truth and
you've been cheating on mom for years
and you left Mom for somebody who's
um psychologically not well it's
cognitive deficiencies and you chose to
walk away from my family and let him
know I mean put it in writing until you
make different choices and here's what
those are going to be
um you've opted out of being around my
family and your grandkids and fill in
the blank and I'm gonna miss you
terribly and I hate that you made these
choices and um
let him know
but my thought is if you sat down and
had a conversation with him he's
probably good enough on his feet and you
would leave that
pretty confused is that right
yeah we've had those conversations
before and it just feels as if nothing
really sticks yeah he's probably a good
talker yeah he can Loop you up in spin
in circles right yeah that's what he
does yeah yeah that's his career that's
his craft that's who he is right
um yeah write it down man and then at
some point you're gonna have to write
yourself a letter
mm-hmm you to you and be really upset be
really honest about the good stuff he
gave you and then be really clear about
what you're going to do next
yeah okay is that fair
yeah and then some days You're Gonna
wake up and just miss him like crazy and
that's what your boundaries are for
you're not going to reach out you're not
going to text him you're gonna have
somebody else to call you're gonna call
your wife you're gonna have already
thought that through and some days
You're Gonna wake up and be so enraged
and pissed off or some days You're Gonna
wake up and your mom's gonna have texted
you and just like with a long text or a
short text and it's going to break your
heart and you're going to get so pissed
and all of those feelings are okay the
real question is what are you gonna do
after that
right right yeah and when those feelings
pop into your head and you have those
moments more than five seconds on them
is a choice I'm gonna just choose to I'm
gonna make cereal and I'm just gonna pee
in it just cause
I'm just gonna eat that for breakfast I
think it's just a choice it's just a
strange bizarre choice
or when those lightning bolts pop into
our head we can go oh my gosh that guy's
the worst
my wife is incredible I'm so grateful
for this home that I live I'm so
grateful I'm sitting in an office right
now I'm a fortunate guy and then we're
gonna go about our day that way and
that's something you're going to
practice over time it's going to be hard
sorry this happened to you man
um
I can't imagine finding this out about
my father
I can't because I'm anchored into them
I'm anchored into them I can't imagine
finding this out I'm sorry this happened
brother
um it's very simple you gotta have the
boundaries and it's gonna be very very
hard over a long period of time uh
holler at me as you go man and I'm here
to walk with you